well 11 of them got copies of his new
book the singularity is near outside
because that's all the publisher sent to
place but so well that it places just up
the street a block in half we get out of
people and order without me you can do
that find it online and those of you who
have copied great stick around a little
while after inside or some of the other
books it is but you're nuts that you
please to nurse how long from thinking
or indeed the next one will also be
instant when CR tortilla his three
peepers who've never been on a stage
together before cleaning Dyson is our
essence on your face they put together
the event has the fun indication of
putting together on stage the subject is
framing sand w
Peter subject is the difficulty of
looking far ahead that will be back
information unless he knows another
large theater like this small painting
of the old tree cannon so we're gonna
pass we don't have a surprise you want
to go to that talk to the chef awesome
for me all along out and just give them
your name time see buck down as 5616 582
and that will know for sure you can get
in we'll keep some secrets and wives and
that people're like this one has windows
to the outside outside possibly we still
get a lot of people we don't stay
outside I mean
this place for questions so green sake
have mercy not question put in write it
down and it's helpful if you put your
name on there and your email address the
email address we'll just in the box if
you want some of the future speakers and
your glacier Sanders baby ain't not baby
cousin Pierre shorts and a nuclear power
climate change the way we get those
questions to the trot is as you go to
hand over the out guys occasionally
stroll up in athletics questions ask
Monica Kelly
the Soul Swap saw that turns this case
is about peace rather than absolute
occurs but it is a great idea ready idea
exponential
we speak today except for joy the rate
of progress every day
because the disclosed of nature of
exponential growth that's explosive
nature of expansion why the future is
surprising the past with long-term
predictions on our wall being overly
conservative nice be better really kind
of took today's research data mildly
optimistic maybe today's research
problems will be solved J Watson itself
said about 50 years we'll have Russian
amazing newsletter I said we've already
done that this is Mike's a radically
remains later about the health benefits
of exploding bug disease it was twenty
percent longer go striction while doing
the opposite of the great power hitters
I'm using our names off human market
this is really critical for this because
I realized that timing is critical to
see things like this is somebody my
venting for your fishing even make sense
for the time we get a lot of today
40,000 people good part of it but
display that dumb language being there
would be 20 million on a 40 million good
the style technology seemed threatening
to channel your genius like Soviet
Union's or healthy faced with a dilemma
be providing their professional
photographer workstations much more
capable than the copy of zero painting
which would destroy intelligent control
wasn't touch we put other supplies
electronic communication fax machines
telephone email using teletype machines
and everybody's in the novels of battle
for having the centralizer ad on TV
station back do think these
decentralizing very rapid do paradox
using half sphere are going to doctors
all to be hard no matter their juice so
let me talk to you about there are some
implications and talk about some issues
that are particular for
long-term rocket planet our critical
issue becomes obvious which is true
ultra nate specific problems Google
stock that's hard to predict if you're
as you well know the cost of a sequence
or resolution ranks game 2014 i believe
it is likely to be accurate overcast
data forward-looking predictions and
predictable anybody want to have that be
over all of this worldwide what was the
other champions of that size is many
undateable and the best
the particle children actions the
overall results of that are an
evolutionary process an order is
inherently sufficiently complex
consisting of many unpredictable element
building some people billions of
projects i Joseph bankruptcies all kinds
of results are perfectly predictable
I'll show you that our spa we're
socially one example many use it as true
for really anything having to do with
information to important observations is
that the power measurements sighs of
human knowledge what sort of measure you
take information is growing explanation
this double time every 12 months
strictly plunger measuring the other for
conservation information technology
ultimately on kompis everything that's
important we're not quite there yet but
these are information component of the
value of products and services is
corrupt assassin coating up
Center there for many types of products
to the media products for example but
even care to sitting in are having an
affirmation quality to the designer
computer system design stations
manufactured in tustin some factories
with automated assembly it's on certain
cards thirty to forty percent
information content and there's a fifty
percent inflation factor for that
information component so getting ahead
of myself let me show you some of this
and then we'll talk about the
implications for friends I mentioned the
paradigm afraid is doubling every decade
examples of this the first virtual
reality combo because he was someone
else miles apart at least as far as the
order for acceptance concern the
telephone that is actually how review
the jawbone this part of part of that
there could be the same rules over all
the conversation now you can create
these virtual spaces it took half a
century be predominant more recent
communication technologies like the way
of personal computers the internet the
adoption by mass audience quote abuse
populations of going a few years time
look at different communication
technologies
decade the more recent technologies
emitted in a few years Connor these
graphs all love except for one another
point out the library they grasp to go
up my axis represents increasing the
number of powers of 10 * Carla attending
each level four straight line on a lot
of the graphic represents exponential
growth now this is an interesting graph
shows the basic acceleration in an
evolutionary process biology
evolutionary so technology detection
technology emerged and violent processes
that led to technology evolutionary
process that living species and
evolution works like needing a
capability increasing complexity with
increase creating a program using that
capability to create the next stage
that's fundamentally why an evolutionary
process accelerates and widely prudes
the products of that evolutionary
processing stage get a conventional
power the first stage in biology like
the into creation of biology in Lucia's
biology to feelings of years to evolve
DNA as nomination first so now evolution
had a little computer system information
faculty projects experiments but then
use that to involve the next day
cambrian explosion robotic right
let's resolve 100 times faster than 0
age of 10 million years then that became
a truer technology in fact that your
body plans to revolve higher cognitive
functions I often kept accelerating Homo
sapiens evolved only a few hundred
thousand years direction only a few
biogenic changes from the earlier
primates so we call the sages really fun
a lot of Roger Stahl a strong jaw began
to rain more of that ring matters to
hire Marcus renal cortex the third ones
to move the pivot wake up one inch so
now we have opposable appendage and
actually us to take our mental models of
the world and actually to reply
experiments that creation of the next
day's evolutionary process okay by
interaction
surprise the technology eight species to
evolve the next stage next stage when
began ten times faster evolution stone
tools fire real early every technology
to tens of thousands of years or
hundreds albums that always use the
latest in technology evolved next age
have more impressed if Kevin to the
century college half a century ago first
computers were laid out on paper
environments without the power a
shooters generations of the computer
systems design software engineers been
specified some high-level formulas and
12 layers of innovative economy get
implemented automatically so we're
always use collation acknowledging to
create the next the intellectual feats
of human civilization today would be
impossible without the integration with
our technology and interesting Leon's
got along with regret it's a straight
line reflecting this continual
acceleration it's been a few arguments
they grew this chart on st. Louis Kevin
is 25 years in a native of the ARPANET
society 25 minutes well we make those
changes it's still get a straight line
it so strange effect you don't affect
things on scale with this chart the
internet
15 years the other objections modeling
points on this chart that get on the
straight line so I took 14 different
listings we're not people trying to make
this is just one call saying cosmic
calendar of the refugees international
history exactly do tabaquero these other
think there's an apartment or thought
with the key events and technological or
viola and you do see some spreading of
the points people do this degree about
having explosion took when language
started the events were but you see an
image or straight loss and it's pretty
much common sense really just put this
between a linear see this is all a look
at a small piece of that soaring
exponential looks like a straight line
and many will just suitably show the
Congress will continue
fully factored in the practical growing
in power potentially were the resolution
of brake pad falling in the year three
special resolution also piece of
temporal resolution computers we have
simulated processes of government power
every year really bad failing to factor
all that into consideration other good
examples of the genome project was not a
mainstream project it was announced 1990
Beijing observers skeptics and just
finished sequencing 110 thousands of the
gentleman and Canadian fishes probably
15 years later disgusted still going
strong fantasy saying motives was there
were here we are community or 15 year
project in finish two percent of the
project but it's the last set of goblins
that they people want to send to 100
was time w manager data every year up to
the present tada now the ongoing
exponential growth of these properties
and information technology don't happen
in a single parent with laws good
example Paragon was not the first and
won't be the last card after the
exponential growth computing for example
compacted by different paradigm so far
on the next one three-dimensional the
light of computing will continue then
friend particular paradise I'm a
capability for exponential growth the
classical example is multiplying more
but in the Commission technology when a
particular paradigm begins to be to
reach its limitations or anymore just
see so the end of row reduced expression
in the next paradigm they're shrinking
back into the 1950s bye into the third
paradigm broke going that your wall they
got picked up without missing a beat
transistors not small tubes it's a
different really different technology so
the of our exponential growth is made of
a series mystery Chester of our power to
let's all bring professionalism
fundamental limit of matter enemies
comprise to support information
processes like competition you talk
about that we work in the answer is yes
there are limits not very limiting
managing serve to something we have
working by parts today he built the one
in field romantic surgery it would be my
calculations are drive 100 million times
more power than the competition capacity
of brain damage in surgery is not the
ultimate in that of energies for
computational processes so the delimited
up very limiting now information can
come whereas paradigm shift Freitas 2010
body follows the information
technologies I mean every deputy
information acknowledgments are doubling
their capacity bandwidth
here you have a team of people now that
gathers data a leader better effort we
gather data on many different types of
information technology so this kind of
thing on a life of its own and enables
us to look at it I still use this
process at time I technology projects
and also to develop distance plastics
evaluated other people's business plans
I think it's a very valuable tools
really understand where computers and
communication biological technology to
be in three years and probably really
make a reasonable estimates dependent in
the future will be more remarkable than
anything we can imagine today we're
going to have to fight as Rome and
millions of other people using their
creativity to apply this very powerful
capabilities but even the men were
amateurs can do today what is feasible
with these technologies was quite
informative and formidable personal
experience when I was at MIT 1960s about
30 40 years ago all the professors and
students yet is one against
or 32 thousand words 36 good memories
where you put out advice supporter
prepared much less power of yourself
today took upper room about this size
the power of dollars there's been just
in terms of bits per dollar than 24,000
36 years you add to other levels of
improvement festivities capabilities
gets coming about every here here i put
49 cranes computers are why we made
crafts time to draw a level the y-axis
represents multiplying application of
power by a pack of 100 goes back to
first Leica captivate processing using
each census and we have really based
computers callum science machine to
crack the German Enigma code you have
back into computers to reuse particular
device an hour
that discrete transistor computer whose
body that's where space launches and
then several decades of circuits you see
very slow exponential growth by the way
this is not a straight line it's better
than a straight line took his three
years together the price-performance
1900 1950 we're not going at every one
year visit theoretical reason for that
second level of the slowest growth rate
of instrumental role as an industry gets
more cost-effective it grows it was sort
of put more money into research the
development of the computer history such
as well as a handful governments were
related projects and academic projects
1950 today's including dollar industry
this is Hans Moravec similar Charlie two
different computers draws trend lines
the later he rose and headlined the
higher the slow hopper I'm getting this
second level of exponential growth and
I'll show you quickly this many jams
electronics but I particularly want to
show you
product but soup the interesting thing
about the supercomputer chart is prolly
to put this together recently it's in
the market is already out of date and
all the news that's come out just the
last few months it's better than we
predicted but this projects 10 to the 16
10 quadrillion calculations per second
for 2013 that bigger significant sense
my estimate of the amount of computation
required functionally in relation to the
brain have four different analysis are
different researchers research groups in
the book to come out between title 14
and 10 to 16 or pretend 16 to be
conservative if you were to simulate
every non linearity every day prolly
every neuron it's 10 to 19 but it only
does necessary everything comes out to
2013 just two weeks ago two different
Japanese companies announced
CBS super computers or their building
will be ready by the 25 we will run
track here perfect different types of
friends that have a great memory
actually that's going to different
technologies this is an interesting
chart is the average transistor price so
1968 aided by a transistor for now that
should be back up further when I was
high school student in early 60s surplus
electronic shops Canal Street led by
something about this day which is
helping really with support circuitry
good luck transistor as well open
transistors for about 40 miles 2030 by
10 million transistors distance regalo
interesting thing is I mean look at how
smooth this pregnant you would think
this is the outdoor some Table Topics
party but this is a measure of a chaotic
activity involving millions of people
and hundreds of companies are many
different countries and accusations of
one country dumping products and other
and economic recessions and conflicts
and wars and hurricanes all kinds of
things and you have very smooth
exponential progression it's a pretty
remarkable phenomena and we see it in
any measure we've looked at
dimension unlike Richard started as a
suffocation key transistor as a
transistor a victim cheaper the better
because the smaller concepts of
statistics of travel so their connection
faster you put those factors together
the average cost of transistor cyclone
has been coming down by half every one
point one year then yet all these other
innovations on pipeline ended captioning
other innovations that processor design
it's done by year so we're doubling the
price performance of electronics every
year and it's also true of other
databases and software and other
measures of information technology
that's fifty percent deflation talk a
little bit later about the economic
implications Congress and what we could
is worried about inflation also you know
at the point that yes it's a good thing
to buy same style for half the price
video later that's going to lead to
the economy information technology
becomes a logical part of the right down
to eight percentage already the cotton
work by the 2020s so people will buy a
bit more but there shouldn't having to
double their consumption in a year but
actually what we find is that we do
better than that repent eighteen percent
compounded growth their dollars for the
last 50 years electronics despite the
fact that you can get twice as much
stuff in every year because every time
project portland's reaches a certain
level of management technologies people
that buy a thousand dollars ten years
ago and going to continue damage process
we have a sort of unsatisfiable human
desire and need for for resources say a
lot of concern about the same thing
neither one person could make clothing
ten times the rate the weavers of pride
that motivation in 1800 is going to lead
to collapse of the economy there won't
be any jobs but people didn't want just
one shirt in one
confident woman also wanted what they
are they and so we consume more Express
performance improves and actually keeps
up with this one keeps out of this fifty
percent deflation so I put this chart
off just show you another random example
this is not nor laws not currently
transistors other great circuits disk
storage so it's shrinking the dead spots
under the genetic substrates different
technical problem different engineers
different companies different countries
same exponential regression not really
significant wattage higher technology
biology learnings understand and to
reprogram biology is information
processing biology is based on genes
genes are little soccer programs we are
training about 20,000 of them we have a
change them recently how much software
do you haven't you haven't changed in 30
months a lot of 30,000 years if we have
programs like the balance on the subject
invention which basically says hold up
every calorie
and that was a very good program 30,000
years ago calories were few and far
between we'd like to change that program
as I mentioned what we did that twice we
got a good result and we actually now
having these attorney jeans off it's
just a merchant lasted three years our
na experience where we have how about
Katie doesn't have to go to the movies
hard to get into Justin for the cell
which is easy in something better
medication is so will latch onto the
messenger RNA expression teen and
destroying attention for being expressed
and we've got the means now trained
teams on there are a lot of genes we
have identified that are necessary for
asus grossest source of heart disease to
progress cancer to progress but every
major disease utilizes number different
genes in order to go through it's a
cycle so there are many very exciting
developments by using RNA parents who
generally particularly disease-causing
genes off their similar diseases james
moore coordinating so on listen exciting
new methodologies to turn genes on or to
add the genes or modified genes gene
therapies in played by princeton genes
into viruses
place what excitedly technique is to
take sellout modifies its DNA in vitro
future dish then examiner's but not
directly than when it's been certified
that reproduces billions of times and
then reject it into the patient's
bloodstream and it works its way to the
right tissues which we modify my heart
cells reject them at least many of them
wound up my partners will just be
discarded this is actually cured
pulmonary hypertension a fatal disease
and animals it's been approved for
either trials there many other projects
using that technique into some other
exciting new techniques in gene therapy
so what I've got such designer babies
with designer baby boomers the many
other exciting by ourselves and programs
to be understanding the Cumbrians
correctly in air is threatening things
that we'd like to correct in DNA
a thousand years this is the new
paradigm returned about the most drug
developers today using this rational
drug design the old paradigm is called
drug discovery and some of that is
automated and still it was a matter of
just finding something that happened to
work with no model of theories divided
work okay something is lower the blood
pressure we don't know why it does that
very great these drugs were crude tools
they had lots of side effects or
discovery those guys i'm your knightress
of the drugs in the market today we're
done this wow the new drugs will be
quite different and a lot of people have
the idea that it should avoid drugs
because drugs are very crude implements
a side effect that is true most any drug
design on the market that won't be true
when we can actually develop very
precise targeted medications that
reprogram biology based on real models
and simulations I'll compile towards
where the early stages of that but
they're very very exciting example in
spices course of the week which block
the specific enzyme that's using a
particular stage about this process and
destroy through CL to the point phase
two trials it stops at the sources which
means to be stopped heart disease
personally everything I had at any one
of these developments and advisories
head
your child but there are thousands of
these developments in the pipeline based
on earth building how to understand
cingulate to reprogram the software
processes the information processes
underlying biology and we see the same
exponential progression basically our
DNA course ten dollars to sequence 1990s
attended today come down very smoothly
and exponentially the amount of DNA that
we collected as I mentioned is doubled
every year that continues and our
sequencing every disease sequencing DNA
aging process into sequencing other
other animals sequencing viruses and
really gaining an information basis for
biology and improve the mountain
simulations other revolutionary
technologies communications many people
ways to measure that he moved around
vandread speed wireless wired up fiber
optic but many different aspects of
communication technology and data
traffic back on speed are doubling every
year roughly this is the number of posts
on the internet this is China mentioned
earlier in after stumbling who's only
few tens of thousands of nodes but
doubling every year needs x thousand
years of done in 20 years civilian in 30
years because of the slow second level
much growth is actually x here but it's
very common phenomena but it started
just 10 years the first reference is the
world wide web new york times with 1993
this in so long ago the first reference
to flaws few years ago Google
business a good internet advertisement
to puzzle this is that same charm on a
linear graph ethical approach would look
like I just came out of nowhere
mid-1990s this is how we experience
technology liberal in their world but if
we look at these lot of different trends
you can see these things company that's
y coordinate it's particularly involving
technology but since information
technology will be accomplishing
everything that's important role
complete including things like energy
and transportation comment on that
support early for everyone to understand
is exponential view of technical
problems another exponential trans major
zation chris electronics expect rising
but mechanical systems are as well some
illustrations that have been circulated
now something to build from aircraft
since 1986 book part of modern
technology which was foreshadowed by
findings riginal comment
physics and prevent us from actual
buildings at the molecular level have
many examples in the book of expressive
projects where people are in fact
template molecules and creating brain
instructions of the little robot that
walks in the validity at the molecular
level and there are four major
conferences on Biological
microelectronic dependencies biomems of
action pudding blood cell sized devices
in the bloodstream the blood stream of
patients is experiments and animals but
then a lot of peeps are on that Abbas
very futuristic and unrealistic we're
doing it today he's not about computers
but we do have blood cell sized capsules
they would you never to be able to do
sophisticated and complex things and
actually perform you gossip entire
community functions and animals today
conferences on the subject one side is
actually cure type 1 diabetes and rats
through the nitrogen capsules done that
way the pores let's insulin out of a
controlled fashion blocks anybody's this
type 1 diabetes autoimmune disease and
it actually works it's not a project
actually to build a version of that for
human testing so blood cell sized
devices is not a futuristic guess it
sounds of utilities all the trends that
I don't you into consideration instead
of what these blood cell sized devices
will be capable of the 20 coins they
will be able to have considerable
computational and communication
resources that could be able lock
wireless local area network computers
and share their knowledge and their
computational resources million
computers can be from one computer when
necessary than a million again so these
nanobots will have considerable
computational resources as you get to
the 2020s this is a desire to looking at
of a robotic wreck oneself or previous
calls it a rest precise measurement
worked out in considerable detail now
red blood cell is part of our ology that
we have a person to you understand
however cells
we have complete model simulations that
actually fairly simple and it brings up
an interesting issue about biology
people say how a chicken vaio p that's
true some people say how optimal it's
absolutely not true an evolutionary
process we all make certain assumptions
early on and then has to live with those
assumptions essentially although we can
come back now to human being we are the
result of an evolutionary process and
change some of those early assumptions
one of those are assumptions is
everything is to be built out of amino
acids amino acids are very limited
classic three-dimensional structures
that can be folded up linear sequence of
amino acids and as we reverse-engineer
biology we're seeing that we can back in
here by six ten thousands sometimes
millions of times more powerful this
Restless I exerted analysis was done
independently in short if you'll place
to set up your red blood cells with
these robotic versions Olympic
strengthened 15 minutes without taking a
breath
go to identify for a lot of white plus
more complex will require computation
and the more intricate mechanical system
but something then should be feasible
one bit 20 20 is actually watch my own
wife what southern microscope it's
interesting it is a cell that has
elements is actually notice in southern
bacterium on the slide and then did a
pretty clever maneuver to block his exit
and surround it and destroy it but it
was very slow devices to do this second
of the kadavo specific pathogens I point
out there we have the questions in the
UN body right already where we download
software into them there's a whole range
of fda-approved or example one
compartments is disease and biological
neurons and destroyed by partisans these
are placed by this computer that's
surgically installed the neurons of that
in the vicinity of the destroyed tissue
and are getting signals from the
computer whereas e-signature viola
happy to do that works well and now you
have a hybrid of biological intelligence
of the latest generation of this allows
you to download the software platform
outside the patient so if we already
have the license in our bodies range
with the devil software we have blood
cell sized prices if you supply these
exponential progressions in the
computation communication and
simulations of biology it's quite clear
about 2020s it will be very very capable
come back to the exponential growth of
computation stand in Ceuta 21st century
we do have to address a question I mean
are we aware of specific technologies
that can support this ongoing regression
and we are crisp predictions that we've
divided por barbra 2002 in town houses
20 22 mar here by 2020 the key features
of transistors on the roads are a few
atoms we won't be able
the law but we will then go the sixth
pattern of which is three-dimensional
collateral computing and that was a
controversial notion of my last book a
special machines cannot back and I'd say
that's pretty much a main street view
today by formed service at one of course
we'll have traditional oven already
working it's small scale and another 15
years ago before we really need them but
are ready very impressive project is
fairly harp intensive treatment ship is
coming out magical music activation
the world a brain which uses the very
slow and cumbersome information
competences and gets its power from the
organizer three dimensions and that's
another example effective of suboptimal
attea biology our internal connections
where our thinking takes place can
compute about 200 digitally controlled a
large exceptions a second it's a billion
times lower than what Electronics is
capable of it communicates through
chemical gradients move in a few hundred
feet per second that's a million times
slower than electronics so ultimately
three dimension electronic circuits will
be much more capable from a hardware
perspective but I would say that that's
not controversial committee but what is
perhaps still more of an interesting
question is will we have the software oh
we just have extremely fast calculators
and that's where this other grand
project comes in or understanding human
brain really understanding is principles
of operation it's got I worked in our
digital tablets and we have only limited
input depends on limited input from
brain science to provide methods and
tools and algorithms for artificial
intelligence and the reason for that is
we have a good name the seeds I'm afraid
up until recently I gave you a computer
and gave you so crudely extensions you
can place outside the box of reverse
engineer this you come up with a theory
the two bella vista theories about Frank
sites throughout the windstar
information to see some activity over
here hissing noise and smoke device and
references where the information to be
stored wouldn't really be able to come
up with a very good theory of operation
that this instruction said instructions
and data field registers and so on if on
the other hand I allowed you to put
individual sensors on individual signals
that you track the signals at sufficient
speed you could reverse-engineer this
exactly if you have training that's
exactly what electrical engineers do
with the reverse engineer and electronic
problem well we are now getting those
tools resolution of brain scanning 3d
volume is doubling every year spatial
resolution as well we are not actually
able to see in vivo and a living brain
individual interaction see them
signaling events are interesting
technology the University of
Pennsylvania difficult do that any other
emerging scanning technologies that
really could provide us the data
seeing the brain work we can see that
not only does the brain create our
thoughts we can actually see a thoughts
create our brain that's very interesting
where's bran has plasticity if you think
about a particular issue you're actually
developing with brain matter scribing
teaching people the violin the robot is
to control these four left fingers
suddenly grows greatly and complexity in
the brain so we really create who we are
but we can understand those principles
we're going to stand now question comes
up okay we get this data to make any
sense of it which is going to be this
fast not be comprehensible David got
cops better what is about the baby our
brains are below the threshold necessary
to understand our intelligence maybe
that's a basic rules complexities system
will only have certified complexity
cannot relent in its own principles of
operation and if we're smarter and able
to understand our great
the necessarily refer to that much more
perplexed government now that is not
what we're finding there are several
hundred reasons the regular have an
update about several dozen of those
regions to reverse-engineer them to
describe how information is encoded with
readings how its transformed how
transmitted and what format to other
regions this is one model and simulation
15 weeks or a quarter century was post
the boy wants us organized and applying
psycho Christie Fest this simulation
gets recycled results of Parts I prefers
to test the human or three reception
it's being used now designing for
front-end speech recognition makes it
accountant conversation gets a pattern
for the background sound something
speech recognition software as if they
will do there's another gracious in
simulation cerebellum subscribe quite a
few of these experiments of the book
cerebellum is significant this is where
we do our skill formation at the finals
wouldn't have two neurons in the brain
and again the simulation once pastor
assimilate to the human skill formation
doesn't prove it's a perfect model but
it does show that we can understand
these ratings of development simulations
that brings up an issue how complicated
is the brain hope if we take a brain
that described all these
concentration patters it's there's a lot
of information its thousands of children
survives but the designs of the brain is
to tanger the general with their way to
go to include the ribosomes and that
actually ate very little information so
the whole genome is 800 million parts to
building around six billion bits 800
million bytes two percent of that
culture party and the other ninety eight
percent well used to be called junk DNA
reaction standouts about John's gene
expression quite it's completely
redundancy this is one sequence called a
linkage between 300,000 dollars if we
eliminate all the redundancy we get 3205
close to 30 book about the small of the
microsoft word 20 million bytes of that
approximately 20 to 24 team invites
describes the design of the brain that's
a billion times smaller than our
estimate on information integrating how
can that be hungry 4095 subscribe
something that's a billion times greater
well computer science we do that all the
time in genetic opera for example to the
daily contact capital
the modern solution to a problem that
important flex that the original design
by several orders of magnitude and that
is actually how the great work for
temple on the cerebellum the genome has
only a few genes only few tens of
thousands of bodies it describes the
wiring of Jenna of the cerebellum which
is staffed with the neurons of the brain
basically says that therefore neuron
types are wired like this our
p10-billion kinds of all we had a few a
little bit of regular this with each
repetition and then this is a stochastic
Lee Weyer cerebellum which has a lot of
random percentage interaction of its
prime time walk my boy gets filled up
with meaningful information by
interacting with the complex environment
does basically the paradigm which the
brain worth of these complex design is
on the order of 40 million bytes that's
not simple I'm not saying it's a simple
system we don't understand that design
yet and accordingly a bunch of how to
interact with each other but it's a
level of complexity that we can manage
it just to show you an example it is the
famous Mandelbrot set it's a very
complex pattern as we zoom in on this
whole piece of it received endless
complexity at every level key difference
Lee complicated the formula for this is
six characters wall so to show you how
on our parent complexity can emerge from
simple rules stephen wolfram it's the
same points really simple cellular
concrete
subsidy it is a cleverly designed system
involved the evidence connected complex
environment and inaudible of dollars of
scalar multiplying some complexity if we
examine the case with which we reverse
engineering the brain the size of the
simulations scale top of detail
conservative estimate that we will have
detailed models of principles of
operation of you integrate by 2020 the
end is already come together kind of
electrical and chemical simulations
region cortex progress into the Sperry
rather this will justice is blind and
copy these techniques it would expand
the toolkit in the artificial
intelligence field that we create
cognitively complex chemical systems and
it will be a very interesting
combination Rivera combined the subtle
capabilities of human intelligence long
enough pattern recognition capability
which is already superior to us remember
bill its effects easily it can share it
Solomon scales we spent years training
17 research computers to understand your
speech and trained about the child of
automated evidence about two hours and
french fries creation who would
gradually prudence market models and
neural nets and then finally learn its
lessons and do a commercial acceptable
at a little speech recognition if you
want your person computer things do the
same things you don't have to go through
that training like you do have to do
with every human child you can just love
the all patterns in one computer it's
called learning software and she's gonna
share their knowledge at 120 speeds we
can share a knowledge to the speed of
light referring to top scorer now that
was a big step or what happens to do
despite the discussions of those
experiments much more limited and unique
thing about humans is that we do have
this expanding knowledge means that we
generation to generation grows as we
pass it down no other ever does that
just touch briefly on economic
implications this is growing our economy
we've got thirty dollars and thirty
dollars there's value in constant
dollars the value of a great hunter
average power in flavor because of
automation and not only does the power
of these technologies grow exponentially
when the sides of the
which if you move around but the
adoption growth expansion is ecommerce
smooth exponential growth is powerful
twenty dollars now you might say the
waiting wasn't there a woman of us
somewhere in this progression there was
strictly capital markets phenomena
capital markets well she looked at the a
message was going to transform every
business model so the value of these
companies that do business model to sort
taking months later when all the
business models everything she had been
transformed overnight while she said I'm
as that was wrong everything went the
other way meanwhile there was slow and
steady but exponential growth with
adoption of these technologies and we
see this kind of Mumbai site psychology
is a harbinger of true revolution to
happen the railroads in the 19th century
have an arbitral telligence in the 80s
and it's now covered with the internet
and telecommunications to maybe a
movement going now in nanotechnology
because really exciting applications in
that effect
gr beyond the 68 year plan of garage in
the paint roller venture capital
information technology is eight percent
economy is growing exponentially will
give Charlie the country by the trick
play it's already deeply influential
every other aspect to the holidays let
me show you one example we've gotta meet
we develop the first law kinetics we
joined attention one of my companies put
this together with personal language
translation and synthesis which another
one my country's developed the first
piece of massage that this is a more
recent generation of that etc sounds
pretty human in this demonstration the
weakest part of the actual Texas Tech
language translation but I was a google
day before yesterday and they took a day
driven approach a little acid google has
not just a search engine for its data it
has its vast databases you can create
intelligent systems if you have an
updated cell organism they have team of
people develop our seed english
translator and nobody on the team spoken
word of our see the system actually
works as well as human question human
translators by after defining the
patterns in all of these examples and
translated text so this is a translation
system i've actually use this talk to
people the girl
depressed quite well this is a
demonstration this is talia demons of
tune we will be able to talk to anyone
event is like to even mentally
regardless of the language earlier una
musica viva la rain in Spain stays
mainly place on it and constant
attention
thank you for your attention other
project we have to work on me with the
team that we have cataract issue the
stock market try to make predictions
about business so these talks will walk
down for a great of time you might say
the attention that you can't predict
what specific companies will do it the
answers we can but we can predict
substantially better than chance what
they will do that's good enough to put
us the position being like the house and
see know how could we lose any bad foot
over 50,000 best because the odds of
slightly in its favor statistically it's
too much guarantees are very likely to
make money that's not money Bill its
overhead so we have to make enough money
go Protection Clause but we were trading
a real cash well significant amount of
the last two years eighty-one percent a
year back my crown lots of my crown
profile
microsoft nasdaq or it's a show slee our
reputation and the advantages a
machine-type record is where as human
kind of recognition is better and there
aren't even technically as you can see
these patterns but no you would need to
look at second by second in the tick
data 5,000 stock so that's why the
advantages for partisan even little bit
forms of human pattern recognition to
then use the advantages of machine speed
the ability and tell us let me talk
about a few scenarios try to address
couple of issues of long-term trends
take the question let's see if they
compiled here 2010 only the next decade
computers will multi disappear they
won't be rectangular objects that we
carry around how much more of a mesh and
communication the world wide web for
worldwide fashion worldwide mesh concept
is where all these devices your personal
computer your cell phone not just folks
into the network but just send and
receive
they're all knows that become part of
the network so not only is transmitting
here best of these other messages are
going through it when you have a message
in connection as really reorganizing
these billions trillions of different
nodes in a kind of a seamless web or
seamless mash of section and development
department so they could drop italianate
place and the communications with
self-organized intelli- off dogs they've
actually adopted in for next-generation
communications Google's is supported as
well so we will have devices are going
to get smaller and smaller that's been
the whole history of computation machine
to a very remote desktop it's they'll
make their way our clothing cannon I and
our colleagues have done
sensory power of the light when we are
building smart underwear swarm
undersheriff event that will monitor
your heart and your lungs particular for
people with heart problems that is the
early adopter market it needs exercise
their parade of exercising right tell
them obviously what we should do is
whatever you exercises have adopted with
your old times so simple thing but we
will computing will be in our
environment to be everywhere we will
have ridiculous computing communication
in our clothing image folder into our
records from our class contact notices
this technology exists on the army
sergeant products board Germans very
interested in using these technologies
to put soldiers and commercial reality
environments rather than they were
inside the weapons beyond predator is an
early step in that direction but
ultimately would be taking soldiers out
of the references to taken place to be
and they'll be a virtual reality might
feel like they're under weapon even if
they are an event unplug the neighbors
tag detection
these last 20 years or captain abrams
tanks because of a lot of exotic
technology but sold you can't just look
outside the window see what's going on
to their energy requirements but this
will be inexpensive figure it's very
high quality in full immersion
high-resolution technology early the
next decade so things like we now or
would you like them together at
artificial auditory reality will be able
to do any virtual reality space is so
ubiquitous will be on I actually have a
technology enables me to be with an
audience and I could see them at the see
me and I look three-dimensional is it
move around I see the lower back I can
walk around stay behind the special odia
but give presentations around the world
you're going to using this technology
but it's expensive today
this will be ubiquitous technology or
the next decade will have language
translation will have a ladies overshare
ways now conversation their virtual such
an astute or anything so it has to do
with motivation share which but
ultimately these these virtual
personalities will be a continual
presence searching for way to be a
struggling with something that actress
goes to name the robot say oh that was
working phenomena level so it was four
five and six kind of tell the search
engines please well that's election
eligibility of property interface we go
out to 2029 will have many turns of the
screw which of the doubling for price
performance of 25 years s multiplied in
high-performance bandwidth capacity of
information technology education
communication a lot of all these
different information base technology by
a factor of a billion they're ready very
influential will have pleaded to a brush
a community breaker to expand the hay
anh Thu tip be able to really apply even
levels of power recognition together
these natural advantages of Shalott
electronic speed it will be a very
powerful combination but in my view it's
not a from alien invasion of intelligent
machines coming from
I compete with us emerging from would
get our civilization we routinely do
intellectual peaks today as i mentioned
earlier navision possible without our
genes we always go out to the next
horizon if ever do well these things
occasionally people won't be motivated
this whole time today mathematician
Pacific mathematical other similar
program and just easily solve problems
and mathematicians hundred years ago
we'd spent months on that doesn't miss
any work on the mixed horizon and we
literally will get free to introduce
technology we will merge with it we will
have billions and battabox in our bodies
and friends keeping us healthy from
inside batting averages directly narh
reversing aging processes they'll be in
our brains the way we have no replies
today it will be much more ubiquitous
because the capillaries in create
virtual reality departments from the
nervous system i were there was an event
about shut down the signals coming from
your real senses replace them with the
seconds that would be appropriate for
the virtual environment when we drink 30
seconds in that virtual environment the
design new virtual reality environments
will be a new art form some will be B
creations with beautiful spaces like
this or completely imaginary
environments that would be impossible in
the real world go there one other person
or thousand other people have any kind
of encounter volvo five senses to other
people people will transmit their whole
flow sensor experience except
neurological processes are motion Valley
web the way people not being there
images from their webcams and whole
experience beavers plugging experience
what it's like to be someone else the
interesting archive experiences that you
can experience or interested that'll be
another new art form most significantly
it will be an expansion to doing the
television repair to expend our memories
a rational functions pattern recognition
would be able to really very directly
expand our intelligence we do that today
obscenely if only AI programs narrow
reality programs would stop today our
economic instruction come to a halt
indication to stop most transportation
would stop there wasn't true 30 years
ago this artificial intelligence
permeating our modern construction today
get a diagnosis located I question from
the electrocardiogram blood cell images
they are workers flying land airplanes
guidance billion dollars of investment
decisions in stock market automatically
the tech credit fraud fraud there's
hundreds of other examples offensive
where research projects say I 15 years
ago I called the narrow AI because it
forms specific functions that used to
require human intelligence if not the
guns actually better these machines but
they're narrow because it don't have a
flexible subtle subtle broad
intelligence of human beings but that
will change and we will actually expand
our own human intelligence with this
intricate merger with our telligence and
Pettis far-reaching implications book
that I would last year across from India
bedroom talks about three bridges to
radical life extension bridge ones what
we know right now and we can really rest
of the overcome aging disease processes
how could I be 20 is it two years ago no
initiative so I babies i heart disease
McAuley died ea7 but these are personal
280 that's 130
education that disease a lot of
biological agent cus you can increase
quality we can really overcome genetic
disposition agency processes as well Sal
was 87 jeans that's how it should be all
of us of what it down health authorities
regressive about reprogramming your
biochemistry you can really overcome
these dispositions we need to do that
like this when our genes involved in two
thousand years ago was not an
interesting species for people to live
past chopper that nine days 30 so i
would like expectancy was the best of
the twenties otherwise you're just using
a precious resources cry every time
we've had technological advances we
request a new identity it's only thirty
seven eighteen hundreds and sanitation
and a biotics those are big technical
advances in double life expectancy in
two centuries it's not going to take
another two centuries to double it again
the next major technology bridge 2 is
the mastering of the information
processes biology biotechnology
variation that'll really reaches
maturity in 10-15 years of being
psychotic Aziz in cancer and diabetes
Easterner into chronic conditions we
there are about a dozen different aging
processes represent a number of them
already first those that will be a
bridge to the 3rd Prince's amateur
Carlton revolution would go beyond the
limitations of biology that really will
these radical life extension so if you
can take care of yourself old-fashioned
wait another 10 years to put the phrase
this horrible century ahead so just how
I landed a brief comment about
appearance of all term planning the
first thing is really appreciate this
exponential view the next century will
be quite remarkable it alone 10,000
years progress ultimately
century by the 2040s which is the day
after the singularity meaning their
radical transformation with reality of
your existence the amount of
non-biological intelligence to create
that really builds upon the apartment
and all biological intelligence that
exists today once nonviolent
intelligence gets a foothold our brains
it will expand exponentially that this
means self-replicating but that's just
the nature of the power of these
information developments across over
point will be the late 2020s 20 30 40 s
go comfortably dominate our view is
still human intelligence my group human
means species that expand our horizons
we can stand around stand the climate to
stay the limitations of our biology we
want stays the limitations of thinking
either the end of the century will be
markedly different than appeasing this
is called singularity metaphor physics
was very hard to see beyond the event
horizon the most radical transformation
you can describe in a mathematical
sable will be billions trillions of
times more telligent sorry how to
describe what that means this is very
hard to describe what's going to what
goes on a black hole because you can't
see inside of life but we do have enough
rational thinking to actually maybe
telligence comments about what it's like
inside a black hole though we've never
been inside one and we could do similar
mental exercise with regard to the
dramatic transformation that people see
in this century this is not a utopian
vision because it's both promise and
peril we go further than 20th century to
see depends on construction amplified by
technologies are very powerful 21st
century technologies we will have the
opportunity to fix it cou things like
overcome poverty the latest United
Nations report shows actually
significant progress in that power and
malaysia world ranked against the cover
ninety percent my 2015 has been similar
partners all around the world itself in
sub-saharan africa we do see however
progress even they are in terms of this
exponential growth of pressure
performance of information technologies
like AIDS drug which $20,000 ten years
ago a year did work very well mother or
pretty well in Africa out of dollars per
patient per year still more than we like
what we should be doing more at least we
actually have the technological tools to
do more now because of all the celery
return will be able to overcome things
like violins ease without a technology
that introduces own dangers in terms of
potential sufferer getting out of
technology I've had partly arguments
with people at cooperate response that
we really need shelter located at a
technology i dream i believe we do that
ultimately strong a out will have these
very intelligent systems that can
protect you all will have all the texts
from pathological day I would like story
University on the back internal what is
that sitting on some other turtles total
totally down but how Pekka cells from
pathologically I actually important
question they were facing we do have a
new X potential risk it didn't exist
forty years ago it's not just Tom
expected something who are vulnerable a
routine Collins laboratory the beans and
the tools existed created by engineered
biological virus oléhonchô that would be
much worse than a kind of prom and the
tools of it all to do this
more widespread that's an existential
risk people by the one we make more
preparations for 911 preparation change
well is it a perfect combination that
people are doing anything about the
Congress and proposed we have a major
program that put a rapid response system
in place that consists of RNA
experienced receivers a device is
quickly created already made granite
space medication to them rapidly gear up
production that's something we could put
in place should do that it will
naturally come about anyway but it will
take years moment that if we haven't had
a cell project to do it so the increased
power of these technologies I believe is
it horrible how we apply them is not
keep just build up our hands whether
these things to my flower Saqqara
whether you have prepared to the cases
before Nevel peril
you
thank you presentation impression here
passengers you have passed you're so
great the first question of many here is
an extension produces the bug roads
different areas that's how we work for
permission is there any card information
or knowledge work is not mentioned well
could you see technologies that are the
energy
more efficiently but there will be
intelligence organization of technology
converting point oh three percent of the
sunlight falls on their energy would be
over 30 we will actually be able to do
that 20-28 solar panels that would be
highly efficient lightweight easy to
install very expensive full of misery be
able to produce eliminating as almost no
material also just because of the
information will be able to store that
anything out of distributed patterning
in fuel cells that decentralized never
not subject to the for child essential
so not other things information
technology particularly think of forms
of information because we have an
aggressive people will come
change there are always ensure
technologies that have really fulfilled
their niche and there are improvements
there which is like the Cambrian
explosion that was rather evolution the
body mature technology does improve them
reach to the point at the between
evolution stop we've been to a higher
level and concentrated higher poverty so
we have we're not making much
improvement in reprocessing sorry we're
making progress in operating systems but
we are working on higher levels and more
intelligent software than conferences
one more of our industrial this is some
question from me lopez how do we know
that similarity in survive are we going
to be aware of it or will like a nerd
and a brain rodents by accident in other
words if the single area here how can
improve
rise of a singularity of a black hole
prison guard don't know cosine Devon
Suzy god we have to be on the point of
no return and you know some theories of
singularity have these capabilities
going to dialogue with us Moravec what
come to mind formulas were growth
exponential growth subtle change in the
formula does happen X exploded through
mathematical singularity
my view is fantastic so the question
from dad were to better his weapons
technology growing exponentially will
individual be able to kill a billion
people for a few dollars serious
question because of the letters of these
technologies provide that's cost a
concern of a few dollars maybe few
hundred thousand dollars you can get
earlier virus it's about and we get the
self-replicating that technology will
have similar concerns there so that was
an actual source of concern underlying
bill joyce one of us these coats or wire
and that the Stanford controversy but
the concern is real and it's led some
people say well it's the latest
technology right now that's pretty much
making technology graves everything will
be under navigator keep each arranged
within 20 years you have to really think
Sean technology to language fellows
dangerous technologies and can keep safe
ones actually Ted Kaczynski the
Unabomber makes this point actually
pretty well written love our manifesto
rice says you can't get a good
the bad parts is they're all insane
technology that will cure cancer also
powers bioengineer by virginia
pathological liars of bioterrorism so
presenting says given all the more
responsible voices have said similar
things Bill McKibben came up with
warming book recent book says we've had
enough Penelope great but let's stop now
which i think is ultimately known as
possible position and also a tenable one
aside from the faculty Peter totality re
state as a break the world to enforce
that with just drivin technologies on
the ground where be even less state and
this concern came up with this offer of
our subscription birds for twenty years
ago the comfort of a quality these are
not sophisticated but ultimately where
we have a big internet a very
sophisticated circle crisis is totally
destroyed world communication and part
of that ridiculous was correct they have
become very sophisticated very
interesting to read hypothesis
and so on but the immune system the
technological immune system that we put
in place is actually been very effective
it is a good example of a new human
design self sub perpetuated
self-reproducing packages or providers
that we've actually done a very good job
generally within hours of most day or
two a new augmentation of the
technological immune system emerges to
deal with these new threats the internet
walked out breathe in few seconds we can
do half as well biological viruses
replicating that technology we do it
very well and a lesson there is that
this is in a completely open system
that's no root certification the
practitioners in software is no
certification products is completely
unregulated industry despite the packets
or pretoria influential and houston
intensive care units and fly airplanes
it is no certification there is
something all the technologies this is
so Excel organizing system has worked
very well some of the specters inscribed
angle choice article of taking the
future dangers as if they were poison on
today's in the other work I do think we
need to put a few Air Force columns on
the defensive side of the equation you
need to anticipate things like fire
terrorism not just five Harrison died
from smallpox aircraft actually design
bioterrorism we need to
these things but these inspectors to
exist and i think it's active most
important problem facing metadata to
prepare the advances for these
existential risks this is one version of
many people's questions is inspired to
meeting whether what will happen when
the paradigm exponential growth collides
with the brick wall of finite natural
resources well we have plenty of natural
resources we have technology now
technology we keep reorganizing the
matter and energy that we have to these
material needs and even a greatly
expanding biological population that
page virtually any digital product is
from use information resources for your
present we have the senator capacity bad
attitudes to support computation
communication is really advanced
increase our intelligence but eventually
ins so we have plenty of resources the
actual amount of his agree sources
needed is smaller and smaller computer
to [ __ ] swallow smaller hasn't done that
would continue to where we have great
tiny computers electronics industry
influence it is editable taro resources
so that is not limitation what um this
is some Stewart granny in this arena
ever-accelerating exponential growth
what should slow
Zach
objective appreciation by the word sex
and the question from Paco a youngin how
do you see the log accelerator to be
accelerating insurance affecting sexual
gratification see it affecting a lot of
communication technologies have always
used for sexual communication interest
early adopter pathology with breakfast
for survival century ordering things we
apply movies and film and other forms of
virtual reality not every times
colorants XP satisfactory but when we
add more sessions to virtual
experiments in virtual reality proximal
senses really good and currently
actually early the next decade do a
horrible emergent visual auditory which
we ought to be interesting
the nervous system will be able to in
environment safety advantages reality
virtual reality and you don't have to be
the same God protect yourself or someone
else a couple can change themselves into
each other see these respective courses
that came to gender subbed out to
someone else
so here's a question from our new car /
if you were a student now seeing college
or graduate school what field would you
get well I you know human knowledge as I
mentioned this unique attitude and I
think the purpose of life is expanding
analysis nothing for the cloud can be
increased knowledge that has some power
choreography or mathematics science
literature music guys that is truly
exciting what are we chatted before this
presentation about how we feel transcend
their bodies but when we create novel to
be our tracks end here buttons are not
warning about violence we are ideas that
is actually what the future rising will
be a lot of cognitive power to be ideas
also being objective function people but
so in order to create ecology passion
that's because they follow your passion
right advice something that you're
passionate about and Oakland about a jar
importantly it is important to
understand science and technology
because that still is the cutting edge
of these advances sometimes a technology
and the language of science and
technology should give another question
from Stuart rain and a lot of questions
earlier you're talking said that the
singularity was just a metaphor so which
will be going
historical transformation it is a matter
for because as I mentioned we can
clearly see young mothers but we can use
our district where we describe things if
you have an experience in many of their
implications but it will be a more
horrible than what we talked about today
because we will have millions of people
amplified by our technology you hold
this period of time coming up a very
creative way to use this technology
nobody thought it was 56 years ago last
question one of your books to use the
word virtuality so what do you
understand what the word God
three-letter word and it's described
many stories and metaphors in different
religious traditions but they all do
have a few things in common they
describe God whether it's cranky old man
making arrangements with people or
strongly like forces for me it's the
University of describe God anything
knowledge creativity beauty love whole
domain so it's an ideal of
these attributes well what do we find in
evolutionary process we find in a things
grow in knowledge creativity telligence
that become more beautiful you do look
at the history of safe biological
evolution if you look at entities that
undergoing evolution in a genetic out
because they become more beautiful they
become ultimately more capable of subtle
intelligence and the amplitude
understand emotional qualities like love
so they become more loving so they're
moving towards greater levels of these
attributes which are tribute to God
without them so they're moving in a
spiritual direction and actually explode
exponentially ultimately become vastly
powerful terms of these attributes which
are attributed to God that they don't
actually be coming to hit in an
exponential evolutionary process but
they do appear to be virtually infinite
from our card limited perspective
ultimately movie and some saturate
battery
beyond our solar system would be
supremely powerful intelligent resources
a contestar emotional intelligence it
will be vast levels of these of these
qualities they would ship it to God thus
becoming godlike as much as we can
imagine prevented some scientifically
Dreman process the other aspect of
spirituality that's relevant
consideration is consciousness we have
entities that we attributed to which
increases intelligence we have to think
about whether other items are conscious
some people say animals are not just
operated by instinct quality although
people say that but we don't have
agreement about that and we will just
making assumptions about of the Athene's
your people all seem to have fallen off
our legends that claim to be conscious
if we have it today characters new kids
video being in claim to be consciously
angrier
subtle cubes of the associate with
really having those emotions but the
essence of my prediction is that in a
few decades these entities will be as
complex as human collagen so we based
our reverse-engineer your intelligence
they will be convincing we will have a
self user will say they're conscious
have feelings and this nautical top of
the stables of a political prediction
with our technology and it's very a lot
of sometimes say well something question
therefore its illusion doesn't exist by
feeling this is actually the most
important question my Grady's not a
central question ultimately sometimes
guns evolved into discussions of
neurology or general criteria really
whether or not Anthony's conscious of
what is feeling to not people attempt a
significant science into subjectively
operations and that it's subjective
experience but we are going to basically
just a pattern stop here but this stuff
is complete
a few weeks ago most of the cells in our
body completely are destroying our
regrown within a matter of months
ignorance without support the components
of neurons the filaments the tubules all
the different components are actually
changed some of the few days he wants
I'm completely didn't stop when I was a
few months ago so what has top nuit
equals pattern of information which is
our patented water mix in a stream look
at this pattern other options of a
similar pattern stays stable come on
Scooby changes a little but obviously
the water to mix it up changes are
repulsive so we are a pattern so what if
you capture that pattern just translate
everything that sailing with audiences
about the substrate should be the same
thing we're going to have graciously
philosophical discussions about that in
mind you capture and patterns I
important if we are expanding houses
it's another spiritual radio be signing
books to that heaven thank you